[Music]
in soda profit is submitted by Lisa a
man is making big profits by illegally
selling Canadian sodas across the border
illegally illegally illegally you mean
Canadian soda to the u.s. skiing we want
to pay big money for Canadian soda
apparently Wow is it a novelty item if I
tell you this I'll pay top dollar for
Mexican Coke and I'm not talking about
the cocaine I'm talking about Coca Cola
I heard that in Canada they pay to have
people just muggle Trader Joe's up to
them Trader Joe's seem popular oh yeah
crazy pretty interesting and we we we
smuggled their pharmaceuticals into
America hmm Macklemore to me because
he's fat and then he likes to talk about
how good Canada and other places are and
then he did this one segment where
people were like I can't get medicine in
the US it's too expensive so then they
go to Canada and then they buy it there
and it come back what about Mexico I was
gonna say well because they live close
to Canada yeah because you could buy
anything in Mexico I was gonna say like
in our brief time in Mexico off the vote
I was like oh [ __ ] there's a lot of
things we give I hear I know yeah did
you go to a pharmacy no I mean we went
on the same tour that everyone was on I
know I'm saying yeah made me feel like
we've everybody what can you buy what
you want to buy right no just the
selection variety was just like 300
kinds of my a girl I mean pretty sick I
know right we'll try them all just got
it at the same time right yeah nothing
else thinks interest me anymore anymore
I mean drugs oh I see cuz my first
choice would have been ketamine Wow it
was a nice kind of drug was it yeah okay
alright so this is Luis 69 you did
mention a little something a little soda
I don't know
a little pump right I don't know if this
is a customer I thought he actually
looks like though it should be little
box like yeah so yes so he has this
Instagram page called rare drink with it
you know drink okay and so he sells soft
drinks that are exclusive to Quebec such
as sprite
peach and crush cream soda and so he
said first day he launched this he
already had orders for five crates with
only a hundred subscribers yes that's
crazy I would try all of those I would
try a peach surprise sounds okay why is
it illegal though because it's illegal
he's technically doing an illegal wait
according to US laws it's not illegal
from where he is a business license he
needs to have an employer-employee
export he's smuggling it yes he's pretty
much also reselling isn't that [ __ ]
you can do that something like I can't
sell you a Butterfinger that I bought if
it stated that you can't like it'll say
like not for individual individual sell
or whatever nobody go see my friend
smuggles baby products into China it's
big right now he's a black market
diapers awesome what's his first and
last name how do you add these friends
he's your friend too you just don't know
what he does oh you just don't know who
you really don't know he's talking about
because dat'll in China like the rich
people there don't trust their own
product is it shouldn't because they'll
be like there's lead in the baby food
why the [ __ ] is there lead on the baby
food there's fiberglass in the diaper
what the [ __ ] happened on the batteries
there's favorite [ __ ] crazy it's
crazy as [ __ ] there's chalk in the baby
milk why the [ __ ] would you put chalk in
there there's no horse meat in the cat
food what the [ __ ] am i exactly thank
you
so they trust American products so
that's why I see him he's he yes he
ships over American like he just gets it
at the retail stores but you gotta be
clever on how he smuggles it into China
and in
there they sell those baby products
that's some crazy [ __ ] mm-hmm so Louis
here he was inspired by the American
company called exotic pop which is a
website where you can find all kinds of
soft drinks and snacks from around the
world or like special kinds of snacks
like herb cereals or whatever like they
have blueberry cinnamon toast crunch and
stuff like that oh so [ __ ] dope yeah
yeah so then he's saying that the
majority of his clients are either lean
dealers rappers music labels or studios
so so so he's saying that they order
boxes from him and like you know they'd
rather pay a whole bunch of money for
this like really cool clear drink so
then the aesthetics so he sells it for
75 to 180 and like for these crates for
24 pack crush cream soda and so they can
make their lean Oh cuz it looks cool
with the clear sort of apparently what's
lean
what's lean haha now I see what kind of
stuff and you can't just get this at
your local BevMo yeah it's not fancy
because these are exact exclusive let
you live in Quebec all those flavors for
the cough syrup uh that are what they
have up there but this is the exotic
disorder to make the leap yeah I collect
rare and delicious sodas that are not
widely available such as have fun huh
Indian clothes good that you drink them
because my mom would collect Coca Cola's
from all over the world and she would
have them on display and then after like
maybe six to eight years or whatever
like it evaporates
she just had like empty cans and there
was just all [ __ ] up oh did she stop
you guys ever have Mountain Dew
pitchblack
to the sequel sequel and
overall credibility where'd you get it
from it was like a sour drinking would
you get from it was like all over the
shelves when it came out oh [ __ ]
and then I in now it's gone did you like
Crystal Pepsi they brought back crystal
sold it on their website but then I saw
it and well you know what you could get
that at the Japanese market I never got
into Crystal Pepsi I did for a minute
when I was a kid and ever since and then
did you get it when I came back no I
just I just saw it I was like nostalgic
but I didn't buy it yeah oh yeah they
they released it for a little bit there
it was going for a lot - yeah yeah
research I was going surge I do you a
revolt
yeah when they discontinued that I was
so [ __ ] sad I was like god dammit
like Mount Shasta cuz Mountain Dew isn't
the same like had that little bit extra
caffeine yeah bro
that's what surge had dude surge was
like [ __ ] injecting caffeine into
your dick dude surge was [ __ ] insane
dude I remember eating like the 12 year
old kid just went running all over the
place with that [ __ ] you do yeah so Luis
was saying that his first shipment he
had no idea about customs or anything so
the complete failure because the FDA
intercepted the shipment and he got a
call from the Department of Homeland
Security and at like asking him if he
had an importer number since he didn't
everything was seized so he what he
started doing is driving across the
border oh so he knew he was doing
something bad yeah but she don't want to
give up his or he still hasn't given up
his five crates yes minded followers
damn so then like he started shipping it
from within the US and so like he says
when he crosses with his cars I can just
put down bless you he pretends to be a
worker thank you for telling us the
information you know yeah why is he
calling you on this [ __ ] yeah yeah I
usually go in my UPS outfit so people
don't think anything but I tell them
that I'm a different person yeah
I'm not that lean soda guy yeah they're
like oh like oh he's like tell re what
car you boy and he and he also dresses
like he dresses he could only find one
of him
anybody looks like a snow cone yeah
they're easy to spot so when he was
doing that though driving across the
border and like just shipping it from
within the US he ended up getting caught
and he got a letter from or like a
customs officer gave him a letter from
the US Department of the Interior and
they also told him that he needs an
import permit and so he ended up getting
a $5,000 fine so now how hard is it to
get that permit I don't know a hundred
bucks and like it's not three three
papers yeah he's probably just like too
lazy to do it right and legit cuz he
could do it a decent way well I don't
know but he is doing this other way now
people what is just sharing it yeah so
she's saying that now he's back to the
or he's trying the Canadian post and so
every week he sends hundreds of bottles
through the regular mail system because
it's not illegal to send liquid or sodas
or whatever it through the Canadian
jackal be good like sent as a gift so
now he's just crossing his fingers that
it's not intercepted once they arrive in
the US are you saying that today it
costs him about seventy six US dollars
to ship per creep - that's heavy liquid
when he sent it directly from the US he
only paid forty bucks was shipping is
[ __ ] expensive dude ok the National
heavy yeah mm-hmm so but now he's told
everybody and it's just gonna be like we
can just find you're gonna look thick
because if they want to get you they're
gonna get you so like can't I start a
business where ISIL [ __ ] peach crash
well there's someone where he uh this
account that he follows this is Japanese
guy that comes out here and whatever
trends are have or what is it visit the
cholo culture yeah so he's like this
Japanese dude and he comes to LA and he
buys cholo stuff to bring to
pant oh that's a grind that a lot of
people do yeah they've been doing that
since like the 80s yeah he loved like
he'll buy a Dodger hats out Gwinnett
Rockies like all that stuff anything
that you name it I've been I've been in
a mall there were like it's all deal
store that's just cholo Central yeah and
I was mind blowing I was like this is
swap meet [ __ ] in there selling it for
like four times the price or more yeah I
just liked following his life because
he's just just so interesting and even
all the pictures of Posey he looks
pretty Mexican even is beat every
picture is still the trouble stamp like
the ballet dance dance like this yeah
dance and then but all the captions are
always in Japanese second position Tony
boloney's writing but I'm just lace is
tight
I like this guy's first position I just
open oh wait that's what I was picturing
what was he doing oh yeah on the instep
yeah yeah well this is first everything
I like that oh that way yes that's funny
imagine Cholas to belly they can open it
really wide
[Music]
[Music]